my talk at the table is president
biden's nominee for surgeon general who
would be the first person
to hold the job twice dr vivek murthy's
experience didn't protect him
from critics during his senate
confirmation hearing last week
will you be able to effectively
communicate the safety
and efficacy of vaccines to those
americans who may not agree
with your policy or your political views
i approach
issues like vaccines and all public
health issues first and foremost as a
doctor
murthy has also been questioned about
potential conflicts of
interest from his consulting work
related to the pandemic
in that senate hearing murthy was
pressed over his political views and his
support for stricter gun control
do you think guns
present a public health emergency
i think that gun violence like any other
form of violence
is a concern to me as a doctor but i'll
tell you that my focus
uh senator is not on this issue it is
and if i'm confirmed it will be on covet
on mental health and on substance use
disorders
well-being was a big point of his senior
medical correspondent dr terry darula
spoke exclusively with murthy before
that hearing tara good morning to you
good morning tony if confirmed murthy
says he would focus
on the growing mental health impacts of
covid19
the number of americans reporting
symptoms of anxiety or depression has
quadrupled during the pandemic
to four in 10 adults and president biden
has asked murthy to take on
an additional mission to restore the
public's trust
in science and medicine one of the
reasons doc
i ask you to do this when you speak
people listen i mean it sincerely
it's a really really important thing to
be communicated now
dr vivek murphy knows gaining americans
trust
will be more challenging this time
around one of the things that concerns
me the most
is how public trust has been so depleted
during this past year people have become
more cynical
more concerned more suspicious about
whether the people who are supposed to
look out for them are actually looking
out for them
where have we gone wrong in the past you
always
will have challenges during pandemic
responses when people think you're
hiding things from them
that doesn't go well but i think who
delivers a message matters too
we need to have experts and scientists
in front of the cameras
going directly to communities speaking
directly to them as opposed to having
their knowledge or their points of view
filtered
through the lens of politics are you
prepared
to disagree with president biden if
necessary
he always says challenge me tell me the
truth
even if i don't like it why should
americans
trust you to do this job for
us so i think my job is to number one to
be open
honest with people to bring them the
right information to show up first of
all and to listen
it's a lesson murthy learned from his
parents after they emigrated from india
his father practiced family medicine in
florida
his mother managed the clinic what they
taught me was that one of the most
powerful tools that we have for healing
is our ability to show up to be fully
present
to listen to what someone has to say
to stay connected during the pandemic
murthy and his wife move their family in
with his parents
on the ladder back in miami where
boyhood feelings of isolation
had a profound impact i struggled a lot
with loneliness throughout my childhood
and i sometimes faked having a
stomachache i haven't really told my
parents about that to this day because i
didn't want to go to school because i
was scared about being
alone again on the playground so i know
what it feels like to be lonely
you know after i left the position of
surgeon general i went through a long
period of feeling unmoored
disconnected from community unsure what
my purpose was
as surgeon general under president obama
murthy worked to destigmatize mental
health by talking about it
last year he published a book about the
power of social connection
just as the coronavirus left many
americans isolated
the rise in depression and anxiety and
suicide that we've seen
during this pandemic have been
staggering
and deeply concerning because even
before the pandemic we were struggling
with a very
very high rate of mental illness
including among our children
what are your biggest concerns for this
generation that's growing up
under the cloud of covid i think that we
will be learning
over the years ahead just how deeply
this pandemic has affected our children
we've got to study what's happening to
our kids so that we can build
the right strategies to ultimately
address the fallout that the pandemic
has created for our children
if confirmed murthy says he will push
for increased insurance reimbursement
for mental health care
and to integrate it into primary care
goals that he says
are within reach we know a lot of what
we need to do we just aren't
doing it we have for example programs
that we could be investing in in schools
to help provide mental health counseling
to kids to detect
symptoms of mental illness early we can
train more mental health providers
but perhaps most importantly tara what
we have to do is have a very different
conversation
about mental health in our country
people feel embarrassed
to talk about the fact that they're
struggling i just want to say very
clearly from the outset that if you
are struggling with your mental health
that does not mean that you are broken
what it means is that you're a human
being having a human experience one that
many of us
have been going through during this
pandemic and many will experience long
after the pandemic is over
dr murthy lost seven family members to
covet 19.
he says it's important to make
meaningful connections and recommends
taking 15 minutes a day to talk to a
loved one
also being fully present and putting
away devices and doing acts of service
both because it helps others and it
reminds us of our own value
and self-worth yeah tara we're all
nodding along as he makes those points
about mental health i mean so important
and connectedness really matters we know
you know him back in medical school
i i believe and he's got a point that he
made at the confirmation hearing about
healing the nation
in part through healing our
relationships and building them with one
another can you tell us about that plan
yes actually we know each other from
residency he was my resident i was his
intern
but i think for dr vivek murthy you
heard him talk about and he does talk
about programs and public health
campaigns and the vaccine and how we're
going to heal
but really it comes down to a change in
philosophy and culture
and healing starts at that micro level
of forging these very tight individual
relationships with family and friends
you know he said to me
how often do we ask someone how are you
how often do we see someone in distress
and walk away because we don't want to
get sucked into a conversation
when he was surgeon general last time in
office he had a policy that at their
weekly staff meeting
each staff member would stand up and
talk about themselves for five minutes
it's really this concept of being more
vulnerable of being more authentic
of being there for others with
compassion and empathy and kindness
it is a change in philosophy that he
wants to bring to office and to america
all right i think that's a very good
idea shawna thomas we're going to be
standing up
the next staff meeting talking about
ourselves sorry she's going gonna love
that that's a new big cheese around here
she's gonna love that yell king's first
all right doc dr turner thank you very
much we appreciate it